[Music]
God all right you need white Amy again
no no I just just waking up just waking
up would you like me to walk in with a
taco what I don't know what does Amy do
to make you happy sometimes she walks in
and gives you
food oh there you
arey I've been right by your side
through everything thanks Amy
anyway no I'm I'm good go away I I don't
care I just woke up so let me let me
drink this coffee oh your neck was not
okay there for a second there b yeah
know I might have hit hit my mouse
slightly off of my desk we
love all right
okay what do we have as far as like
walkies and stuff go we need we have one
walkie-talkie and one pro flashlight
well we got one you can't you can't
discard this not pro flashlight like how
do I get how do get walkies all right
airm we got some walkies coming in all
right airm what else do we need uh we
need to pick a moon well I don't think
we need anything else as far as spending
money right now we probably want to save
up for some of the more expensive stuff
there's a manual where's the manual is
this the manual oh this is oh wait this
was your ugliness report sorry in the
margins there's manuals right next to
how bad your beard looks to uh your
posture is really slumping uh to your
feet stink
horridly uh it actually says you look
really good bald so that's actually in
big with a star next to it and
underlines and highlighters like you
look great we're going to boys uh but
the rest of you from your eyes to your
toes is pretty much awful and also it it
says how to play the game toes
everything but your nose it stinks
it's oh yeah remember that refence
I'll take this
flashlight so you can leave this walkie
in here cuz there's three walkies coming
in spicy on the next ice cream truck
okay where we where's the ice cream
truck this is V yeah shouldn't it be
playing
songs by the way I fixed my internet
guys
hey who who wao I almost died I swear to
God you guys were not going to warn me
you guys wait you watched that come
right down on my head didn't you you
you're walking I'm not over this I'm not
over this wait you stood there looking
at me I remember being like yeah wait
just looking at me and then you looked
up didn't say a
word well you noticed I was standing far
back I hope far back from what I didn't
know where it was going to land the fire
was your warning Mark the fire
was actually my warning cuz that's the
thing I first saw I feel like you were
sufficiently warned as to save your life
well my life has been saved so I guess I
can't really complain but I'm watching
you too U you know what I haven't done a
single time I I haven't scanned anything
I was just going to say I just right
clicked for the first time since we've
been playing and I heard you all talk
about scanning stuff but I just right
clicked it
scanning
Keys oh you never did the
scam
accidentally and didn't know that I did
that I was like oh that was weird that's
probably a creature SC right now Bob and
it'll show you the main entrance
see
a guys that's so helpful that is really
helpful okay I mean do we all need
radios I mean yeah hear
that uh I just checking if we all need a
radios are we all going to split up yeah
we should absolutely go one well there's
three doors and there's three uses oh
this is not a door there's two doors and
there's three uses and we'll find a
third okay uh there's another door over
there I could take that one found a
remote
guys say what I found a remote I don't
know what it does a remote to okay do
you hear that yeah look look at the um
look it's like a TV clicker push
it it clicks but it doesn't do anything
it might also just be a remote you know
like a leftover remote um possible why
did we
hear yo Wade we heard you scream like a
little
baby wow there's no way he's already
dead right yeah the he's he's um no shot
already dead yeah no shot
oh
a all
right okay what what was it I didn't
even see it was a it was a spiky black
something or other uh made of Shadows
and Nightmares it stared into my soul
for a beat and I felt a turn stretch
part before my eyes and then it charged
me did you scan it I did not all right
I'm going see if I can scan it all right
cool I just realized you have the
flashlight uh so that's probably going
to go well
uh don't worry its eyes I think glow in
the dark it's uh its silhouette is
burned into my brain oh uh there's a h
gr deer it appears to be
slime yeah I don't think that was the
thing does not have eyes oh there's
multiple slime thingies
okay no the thing in question had Spikes
all over it I definitely remember spikes
oh I have a feeling if I let the the
Slime touch me I probably die and and
it's blocking the entire way yeah don't
do that I remember that happening to uh
you or Wade specifically and that was
bad I'm really stuck here I was going to
try and see if I can get W's body but
like uh well you want me to go to oh
there's a uh there's a slidee right by
the entrance all right um well there's a
there's a there's a fire exit over here
if we go in I don't know if we can go in
the fire I I don't know if we can go in
the fire exit I think those are exits
only Bud ah no you can go back in when
I've gone out of fire exit oh I went in
let me see yeah I've I've been out of
this one before and you can see it on
the bridge here if you look to the left
if you use your eyes did you jump down
you were kind of hobbling like holding
your stomach you got you got poop I'm
fine I'm fine all right
well o
well that's just my flashlight is out of
batteries oh okay wow it's real dark
over here Mark wow that is like G or
something w w hey what was that what was
that you should probably take a sniff
what here I'll use my remote see if I
can turn it off yeah my flashlight is
dead and I don't know what's going on
there do you want to do you want to try
and jump over this way yeah yeah I'll do
that um here let me drop my flashlight
cuz it's useless but it's value so all
right here we go uhuh okay all right oh
nice nice all right that might to your
left there yeah oh I see yeah uh-huh
okay made it oh nice nice all right um
I'm going to come over I'm going to come
over I'm going to come over what is this
what is this I got a rubber duck and a
baking
pan oh oh
oh I meant to jump onto the
thing hey Mark that's exactly what
happened to me I tried to jump on the
room we both we all three died the same
way we just fell off the thing ah man I
so proud of you for remembering the fire
init you guys continuing on look
uh that could have gone worse oh no what
happens if we don't meet the quota oh
there's one way to find out no is there
a way to turn the lights on in this
place yeah why are they even off yeah
what what is going on where's the God
dang light switch here if you're facing
the monitor for the left wall why are we
even not questioning this is bad right
yeah is there someone else if you know
where the light can you
help
oh oh there it is there it is okay all
right that
was that was awful okay so if we need to
really dig deep and do good here what do
we do cuz if I don't want to not meet
our quota our boss seems kind of um
tentacle and people think probably right
now that we're incompetent in our job
but if there's one thing I know it's
said I love the company I love the
company I love the
company okay okay okay all right we we
all yes the yes yes stop stop yes yes
yes yes but the company will not love us
unless we meet our quota true we got
work to do flash light walkies on the
way down boys all right sounds good uh
we'll bought all of them I think there's
a walkie over here to get
one right there
okay thank you so so Mark I don't want
to J anything but do remember there can
be quick sand here okay should we do the
thing where someone's in the base
guiding uh we can be though right now we
probably need to get as much as we can
at least for the first run in the we
make multiple runs to the ship oh did
you get that that makes sense where are
you guys you were going you were going
the right way if you leave the ship you
go to the right I see I see I see okay
all right
so no way he just
died got him you dummies yeah I'm not
that stupid well now you're definitely
going to die okay yeah no I'm right here
hey propane
tank oh
yo you guys want me to take this
chemical jug back it takes two hands
yeah definitely yeah at least bring it
outside Oh Oh I thought you guys were in
no we weren't even there yet you you
took a more direct path than us I guess
oh okay well I all right I'll I'll take
this back to this
thanks all right chemical jug is inside
the ship good work thank you this
teamwork kind of feels good uh my
inventory is full but I have a stop sign
and an egg feater are those things I
should take back to the ship I'd say
scrap is scrap but I I don't
know you can I mean you definitely can I
can show you guys where I found a few
more things too all I'm coming back
in go left and then left again left left
and left
okay
hello
hello oh there you are oh I can take
that back if you want I've got full
hands yeah I know there's more stuff in
here all right okay maybe we both make a
run back oh the fire ACC right here too
we just pick fire oh oh cool well that's
convenient uh there were some things
there was at least one thing in this
room somewhere I is there an eny a
rock oh V type engine and another
key yeah
I around near me I don't know if a
moving rock there's like bees and stuff
out are you outside
going back to the
ship okay there's a fire oh yeah that
that toy is
horrible yeah there's some things that
are drawn to sound all right I'm on
observation
Fellers okay all right there's a bunch
of stuff outside the fire exit oh should
I come very yeah yeah let me come and
start grabbing stuff it's outside the
fire exit down downstairs
yeah it's two things that require both
hands too so it's pretty valuable stuff
I'm
coming beast
beast F these are slow uh not the
Beast are C
may all right well if you're not
threatened by life uh should be going
another engine
over I'm at the fire exit uh I see one
of you hello yeah that's me uh so yeah
we are swimming in we got two engines
one chemical jug yeah uh the the engines
are and the chemical jug is uh here I'll
actually take one of these back with you
to guarante cuz this is a lot of stuff
yeah that's crazy yeah we're doing like
really good I I don't know what happened
every other time oh yeah the
bees the bees uh you hearing like crazy
noises is that the toy carrying yeah
it's a toy you're carrying but it don't
worry it should be safe out here uh
probably care for that no it's probably
fine anyway that was that pumpkin the
thing that rolled at you it might be I
don't like it oh oh yeah I wait there's
what's that oh oh my God oh my God oh my
God
wait what do we do if there's a big
giant walking around by the
ship
Mark oh my God oh my God God scary Wade
there's a giant
Wade yeah yeah I'm
good that's
prising the doors to the ship is closed
if you're coming to the ship let us know
ahead I I don't
like did you do that yeah I did that oh
no I did not do that I did not do that
Jes Christ wait do that I don't
know wait if we talk to you is it a
problem I'm going to take that as a
[Music]
yes my God
here is that just the door the door has
a battery oh
no wait is getting closer wait is
outside Mark he's coming okay I'm
opening it yeah yeah yeah yeah open
it he's close he's on the
ladder Wade brought two twoed items
that's what he's doing right
now oh my you're so close wait you're so
close
oh oh it's so
close let wait he's coming we going to
run for it okay holy God no do do you
need the other thing do you need the
other thing yeah we're good we're good
yeah close that door get out of here get
out of here get out of here go go go go
go go yep that was what was that what
was that that's terrifying I don't
actually know what they're called I
didn't see called Tre no I didn't get
close
to oh man we did there I was I am the
wor I would be dead in a horror movie
because I was just like oh my God
pointing at it
like literally it walked in the screen
and my I was
like oh man my dude dude yeah but we got
a haul we might make quota I think we
will after just one good day so fuing
good at video games holy cow we are the
best non sellable valuables over here by
the that's a good idea don't forget to
charge your stuff too yeah I'm putting
stuff in the like the locker I did have
to leave a key behind but
like that's okay needs the key yeah we
could we could sell the boom box if you
guys really wanted
to I think the boom box could be useful
I I won't tell you why right now but
luring things away what do you mean
dancing to increase our mood you figured
it out well both
all right the
dancing okay is there a monster that you
need to dance to
appease
[Music]
wait
oh all right wow it was not
happy somebody honked a horn at it I
think who honked the horn at it whoever
carried the horn over I guess all right
okay is that everything we had to sell
why is this flashlight staying on it's
weird I think it's not all sold do I
need to like ring do I need to ring the
bell or something I just I just did
there
we okay how much money did we get oh9 39
nice weed it
yeah
we the compy the compy
hey
you all right okay so that went
surprisingly well inside the facility
why we got lucky and found a loot room
we got in there early enough to where
things weren't going
horrible wait does that matter are you
saying we Dilly DED I'm saying the more
you wait the more things come out to
play so no Dilly dallying
$4.99 okay I don't think we're making
that in one day always no we can do that
I got low low expectations on that one
well it's probably fine I think we can
make it no sales no sails well we don't
need much just I would take another Pro
flashlight cuz those baby flashlights
they do not last this place is clear
this is offense I think we've been here
before it was the only one that wasn't
like ah the desert with the quicksand
everywhere what's with the pumpkin this
is followed us I don't like seasonal
update or something I don't know where
does the thing
land right around there mark somewhere
right around where you are oh oh oh
oh you weren't even going to warn me
yeah Bob you he wasn't going to warn you
he was not going to warn you fire was
warning enough no no you see you think
that but only if you look up all right
so we got
flashlights good on charge all right
boys let's do
this is there a shorter path to the
place or is this it yeah this is the one
that's kind of a whole thing to get to
that's a pain in the ass watch out for
quicksand watch out for frecking
pumpkins yeah what's with the pumpkins
is the season is it okay uhuh T
not isn't pumpkins are pretty win who I
did not have any Sprint juice in my in
my
bars yeah make sure you're charged up by
Bob he made it just jumped again
Bob oh boy all right I'm going to run in
all right all right going in all right
good luck get
there seems good so far uh left is one
of those jumps there is a room over
there but uh I don't want to make
it we're right behind you
Roger I've made it Mark good I'm glad
okay right right right up top is a dead
end uhoh is that a mine or a c I heard
the beep beep what you hear that beep
beep
noise
no did you did you say you went left
already
Mark yeah I went left left is a nogo
right is a noo it's only
downstairs have you messed with these
yet Mark
what it's horrible
steam do you got
to what are you okay there's a valve in
here you can turn it off are you hurt
does it hurt
you come off the valve right there oh
okay you can
see that's loud loud and
scary okay all right there a key here
already got one all I'll grab it grab
that
one
okay I can go back and open this door
from the ship I can't do it here let's
see if we can grab some loot first never
mind we don't need to oh yeah oh it's a
dead end what the
freak all right we got a door at the end
of the hallway
here
whoa Bob you still with us all right oh
that's land mine oh oh oh land mine oh
my God oh my God hey it's that thing
that killed me before well don't open it
hate those
things okay uh so yeah that's not
good okay I'm going up is there anything
to do about the turret being there I can
from the ship yes from here no leak
anybody see a
valve oh my God Wade oh no Wade Wade
Wade oh
no Wade got blasted trying to go for the
steam valve that means the land mine's
probably not gone oh wait it's probably
fine and I got it I got it I got it I
got it oh man oh my God he got too young
so young all right you SC ahead you see
what's up there I I'll figure out oh oh
my God oh my God get the next room close
the door get to the next room close the
door what if they open the door I don't
think they
can okay um uh uh you're in charge now
uh what do we do what do we do what do
we do what do we do what do we do to the
next room go yeah
[Music]
run